let me just recap this ball smelling
thing richard was here on monday and you
said i want to smell your balls and he
said to you this is such a silly day to
do it because they showered sunday night
unfortunately i showered last night i'm
here till wednesday wednesday they come
in wednesday and smells like step by
before the view
yeah that'll be funky by wednesday would
you do that for me i would love to see
you smell his balls uh sure richard tell
sarah what has happened since sun since
monday when she was here so she knows
what she's smelling so three or four
shits
i masturbated
three times
without like cleaning up like when i i
lay in bed sometimes i'll masturbate and
then just pull my underwear up after i'm
done all right so get get in the chair
get naked and i smell your
[Music]
your legs are spread richard you're very
provocative
all right hold them up
yeah
[ __ ]
you're really brave i think this is the
funniest thing i've ever heard of get in
there so i don't smell anything yet well
you're not close enough
like gabby's got on a gas mask
[Music]
you were about six or seven inches away
from his balls
oh she can't stop gagging you really
smelled it bad huh
oh my god how bad is it
it was a hint of raw sourdough dough
in a vat of mayonnaise
that was in a trunk
of like a 70s car
for the summer for the summer right the
hottest summer of the year